let's talk a little bit about the
Canadian trucker Convoy um this is you
know it's it's uh I don't want to say
rare but it's not super common that
something that really starts in Canada
and remains in Canada for so long
becomes such a major U.S Story the US is
very U.S Centric as many of you I'm sure
no but part of the reason why the
Canadian trucker Convoy has become such
a big story in the United States is that
it's become sort of a pet issue for
right-wing media right-wing media has
been supporting and inciting the trucker
Convoy making them out to be heroes if
you look on Twitter there's all sorts of
folks including uh former leftists and
right-wingers and so on and so forth
saying this is just it's incredible
Freedom these people are just doing an
incredible thing never mentioning the
radical right-wing Nationalist and
xenophobic roots and organizers involved
in the Canadian trucker Convoy not
mentioning that many of the mandates
that they are supposedly protesting
against are being slowly dropped anyway
as uh at as sort of logical based on
what's going on with covet numbers
they're not doing any of that stuff
uh but this week something very
interesting happened which is that on
the Fox news program the five Geraldo
Rivera who I'm not like a fan of Geraldo
he's a he was a trump guy
um he said a lot of things that don't
make any sense but every once in a while
Geraldo will it's a broken clock that's
right uh every once in a while he will
call out Fox when they are peddling
disinformation or inciting or spreading
propaganda or whatever and Geraldo had
the audacity I guess we would say to
tell the people on the five you guys
have been inciting these protests you
guys have been inside they don't have
that much support in Canada let's take a
look at it and the panel very very
triggered by Geraldo killing it well you
know as it relates to that Trudeau in
order to I understand that in order to
uh to use this national public emergency
act Parliament has to put his imprimatur
on it so no it wouldn't two weeks
Parliament has to vote on it uh my
understanding is he's not that popular
in Canada how is he going to put bring
this to an end you know it is not that
popular in Canada judge is this trucker
this Freedom Convoy right what about the
freedom of the homeowners to live in
peace what about the freedom of the
shopkeepers to do business what about
the freedom of the Geraldo when it's
black lives matter or and the nebulous
antifa protesting that's when you care
about traffic people getting to work
businesses Etc when it's the trucker
Convoy you don't you're not supposed to
care about it Auto Workers to get parts
where they were burning down the federal
courthouse in Seattle I did more than
that I condemned this and the funny
thing is that line plays well whoa Judge
Jeanine really got him on his hypocrisy
no Geraldo has been clear no matter
who's protesting he doesn't want
destruction of property uh fires
blocking traffic whatever I condemn
anybody who who feels so he did it but
what violence is so empowered that they
can take away your rights to establish
their rights what rights are not taking
away they're taking away the right of
the homeowner to sleep in peace the
right of the shopkeeper to do business
rights be taken away
they're actually being welcomed you you
are this conservative meeting you have
one person you're talking to in Canada
it is conservative media that is that is
has gone from support to incitement
um
are violating the rights of others in
Canada they they say we're inside here
the polls that I see the Hub Ledger
ipsos these polls all show between 65
and 69 of Canadians oppose these
truckers true because this has gone on
long enough oh that's something to show
the evidence yeah they have a very short
open your eyes and look no no I'm
actually I actually read and do research
yeah well the research seems to have
confused Greg Gutfeld very very
significantly but Heraldo is absolutely
right and then they start fighting about
who is actually more working class in
this entire thing
I think it'll work every day call them
essential basically didn't provide them
with what they needed and then in one
stroke of a pen now how funny is that
because that's what we did in the United
States too under Trump make them go to
work don't give them the things they
need except by by you know it's like
pulling teeth but they they were
defending Trump's handling of covet one
day he said actually you're no longer
essential workers yeah now you're
non-essential yeah it's very rude but I
gotta regret I have to respond to this
thing because Geraldo says blanketed
right-wing media is inciting and it's
essentially he's also implicating us
because we aren't defending them that's
exactly right that and Geraldo is
correct to do so I'm okay with that
because the fact is we've always been on
the right side we are not like the right
song we're not the rights we're not
we're not like Geraldo you're on the
political right but not on the correct
side you know Geraldo which has a
disdain for the working class
I am not working yeah mentally right go
drive into your that's after 50 years of
hard work and more charity than you'll
ever do in your entire life my point is
you don't like these guys coming up
first the I you know Geraldo has a lot
of flaws he really does but the idea
that the reason Geraldo thinks the
Canadian trucker Convoy is nuts is
because he at I mean how old is Geraldo
at this point he's got to be close to
80. yeah 78. the idea that now 78 year
old Geraldo who has you know accumulated
assets during the course of his life the
reason that he's opposed to the Canadian
trucker Convoy and the inciting of the
trucker Convoy by Fox News is because he
drives a Bentley if that's true or
because he has now has assets there is
no evidence of that whatsoever and it's
just so funny to hear these very people
who when it's convenient they support
the rich guy from Queens and they don't
talk about how Trump's total totally
disconnected from the average
working-class American when it's
convenient they ignore that but then
when it it's convenient they'll say well
Geraldo drives a Bentley and Geraldo
really struck a chord here he's
absolutely right that these folks have
been inciting and at the end of the day
the the Canadian trucker convoys a
reactionary movement it's it's a
reactionary movement they they want to
go to the status quo merely for the
previous status quo merely because
that's what it was they don't want
vaccine requirements they don't they
don't want anything and of course these
things are going to fall off as we're
already seeing them fall off but um that
that it you know what the police by the
way oh I should even mention that
there's a video which I'll play Here
Without audio of Canadian police shaking
hands and hugging the trucker Convoy
people when you have the support of the
police as well as of capital in your
movement you have to consider that it's
a reactionary movement and it's not
always the case and I want to be careful
about making blanket statements but the
idea that this is some kind of you know
working class Uprising representing the
predominant opinion in Canada there is
not a single poll that suggests that
that's what it is and some of the main
insiders of this entire thing have been
American right wing media one of our
long time sponsors is vincero collective
I love vincero's watches you've heard me
talk about them before they now offer
sunglasses and a bunch of other premium
accessories for men and women vincero is
committed to creating exceptionally
crafted watches and accessories and
doing so ethically fair pricing carbon
neutrality vincero puts their principles
first which is important to me I just
picked up the Rogue from vincero in
gunmetal and red I love the intricate
design on the watch face and the
multiple sub-dials the durable black
silicone strap looks great with just
about anything I'm wearing in all of
vincero's products whether it's the
watches the glasses men's or women's you
can just see and feel the quality so if
you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect Valentine's Day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
Collective is giving my audience 15 off
all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below